-♪♪ J-J-J-Jinx ♪♪
♪♪ J-J-J-Jinx Challenge ♪♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We read a category
from the card.
Then I'm going to count
to three,
and we both say something
in that category
at the same time.
When we say the same thing,
it's a jinx,
and that's a good thing.
-It's a good thing.
-Yeah.
We want as many jinx as we can.
First,
let's put on the jinx glove,
which will help link our --
-[ Exhales forcefully ]
[ Laughter ]
-Help link
our hands and our minds.
-Ah.
-It will help link -- [ Laughs ]
-Always.
I've always, always wanted --
-Oh, this is fantastic.
-...wanted to share
a glove with you.
-This is -- Already, it feels
like we won, doesn't it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right. Ready?
You ready for this?
Let's see what the first
category is.
-It's like marriage.
-Yeah, it is.
And when -- when we jinx,
I don't know what we do.
We -- We do that, maybe.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, if we jinx,
but if we don't, then --
-We kiss through the glove.
-Yes, exactly.
That's what I'm doing.
-He's not into that.
-Let's see -- Sure.
I'll do that.
Yeah, yeah.
-You don't have to.
It's just a suggestion.
-Yeah, I mean --
I don't need the glove at all.
We can get rid of the glove
and just get
right to the end of the game
right now.
-You put the glove on.
-[ Laughs ]
-I never wear gloves.
-That's true.
All right. Here we go.
First category is...cocktails.
One, two, three.
Martini.
-Drinks.
[ Laughter ]
It's my first time.
-Oh, yeah, it's your first time.
It happens to everybody.
Don't worry about it.
-[ Laughs ]
I'm just nervous.
-Three, two, one.
Gin and tonic.
-M-- Tonic.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Sad trombone notes play ]
-I couldn't think
of one cocktail.
-Of one cocktail.
All right. Come on.
Let's feel the connection, man.
Seriously.
-The glove is --
-Enough playing the game
in front of the audience.
-Ha!
-Let's have our real --
Let's have
our real hearts speak out.
Ready?
-I'm not even gonna look
at you now.
Here we go.
Dog breeds.
-Air--
-One, two, three.
-[ Laughs ] Labrador.
-Golden retriever.
-I said air.
-Yeah, air.
-I thought you said
"dog breathes." Air.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah. Dog
breathes air. That is correct.
-It's your accent.
It's your accent.
-Does a dog breathe air, judges?
[ Bell dings ]
Thank you.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Disney princesses.
One, two, three.
-Fr-- Aah.
-Elena.
[ Laughter ]
-Aah!
-Oh, I got one, I got one.
-Wait, wait, wait.
One, two, three.
Moana!
-Mickey.
-Oh, there you go.
-Minnie.
-One, two, three.
Elsa!
-Elsa!
-All right, there you go.
Does it count?
[ Bell dings ]
We got Elsa.
-That was good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Dangerous sports.
-Oh. Okay.
-One, two, three.
-Football.
-Rugby.
Wait! I think it's the same
thing in Australia.
-Depending where you're from.
It works! That's a jinx!
[ Bell dings ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-More kisses. More kisses.
-Tools.
One, two, three.
-Shank saw.
-Jimmy Fallon.
There you go, yeah.
There you go.
I thought
you were going to say --
I thought we were going to get
a jinx on that one.
Here we go.
-Oh, never, never.
Nicknames you call your spouse.
One, two, three.
Honey.
-Love.
[ Laughter ]
-One, two, three.
-Mi amor.
-Cutie.
[ Laughter ]
-Is your wife Spanish?
-Yes.
[ Laughs ]
-Te quiero.
Okay, one more time.
-One, two, three.
-Darling.
-Despacito.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad trombone notes play ]
All right, we got a --
Here we go.
Last jinx right here. Ready?
-Warrior. Okay.
-Countries that start with "A."
One, two, three.
-Australia!
-Yes!
-Chris Hemsworth, everybody!